so hi everyone uh thanks for coming to
itcs 2022 to session 22 as well uh this
will be on analytic methods in computer
science
we have five thoughts line up for you
let me briefly introduce them and then
give the flow to speakers
the first talk uh is about
a mixing of three term arithmetic
progressions in quasi-random groups by
ami bengali prahladarsha surya roy
so basically this paper considers
what happens to arithmetic progressions
uh random arithmetic regressions in
quasi-random groups and it shows that
they mix well in a
in a natural way answering a
question of covers
the next paper is about non-party random
groups titled mixing in non-constituted
random groups like covers and immanuel
viola
so basically in this setting uh
one has to
refine what it means to
for takes things to mix well and this
paper does that and also gives some nice
connections to the communication
complexity
uh the third paper
is a study is maximum constraint
statistics problem over non-emerging
groups
in particular max three lane over known
a billion groups with universal factor
graphs
and by ami bengali and alexa stankovic
and uh they used some
non-evaline for analysis to prove uh
inapproximate ability result in this
setting
uh the next paper is recital separating
the np hardness of the growth and leak
problem from the living rothenbig
problem
by vijay bhattipralu evenly and madhu
sulciani
and basically in this problem they show
that resending the hardness factor for
the growth ending problem
uh it's strictly smaller if the matrix
is pst
that's essentially separating these two
problems
and the last talk will be uh convex
influences by an india there
is a radio
and in this uh paper they define a new
notion of
influences
in a gaussian space for symmetric convex
sets and they prove various nice results
about it
so uh
so that's it welcome to the session and
uh i'll let the flow to the speaker
great
thank you
so i'm gonna
share my screen quickly
oh so you um you guys can hear me well
and see the screen right
yeah
okay great so let's start um hi i'm
soria i'm a phd student at uc review
site and this talk i'll i'll be uh
discussing
mixing of
three term populations in cross random
groups and this is a joint work with uh
so let's begin
so the starting point will be you know
very popular result which is the
expander mixing lemma and
and this lemma what this ml says
so if you take h to be an expanded graph
and let's consider two functions f1 and
f2 both of them are bounded and the
functions are from the vertices to the
complex numbers
then you look at two expressions so on
the right side you have product of
expectations of individual functions
which is same as you know when you
randomly and independently sample uv
from the vertex set and compute the
expectation f 1 u times f 2 v
and you compare with this left term
where you do not sample u v
independently anymore instead you sample
just random edge
u v
and then fade again u uv to these
functions and compute these expectations
and mixing levels says if you have like
a good expander then these two terms
will be close to each other
and
this is very nice in the sense that we
know there are you know constant degree
d expanded graphs so are there we know
how to construct them
so
this is a very nice example of pseudo
random behavior basically because we can
approximate the right side by the left
side um by using way less
amount of randomness and this cause um
because of this this has a lot of
applications in theoretical computer
science
okay
so now uh
let's ask the same question but you know
slightly different setting uh so we're
going to consider instead of our graph
we're going to uh consider h to be a
uniform hyper graph
um but um you know again we have like
you know um so same function so but
instead of two of them we have three of
them open bounded
and again we look at similar kind of
expressions on the right side you have
product of expectations um
basically independent sampling or over
the vertices
uh
on the left hand side we sample u v w uh
as an edge then fitting into the
functions again and we ask the same
question like if they are close to each
other
but over here we ask this question for
specific kind of hypergraphs but the
vertex set will be a group
what kind of hyperbolas we're talking
about there'll be two of them so h1 and
h2
so h1 uh verticet will be the group g
uh the exit will be defined by e1 what
is e1 is the set of all non-trivial
doubles that look like this x comma y
comma x times y okay non-trivial meaning
we're going to ignore edge cases such as
like x and y like ones things like that
and both x y belongs to uh group g
so that's the definition of hypergraph
h1 for h2 e2 will be the set of all uh
non-trivial
doubles x comma x times y comma x times
y square so it's the set of all uh
nontrivial artificial propagations in
the group
so this two hypergraph will uh consider
now you might ask the question like why
these hypergraphs what's interesting
about them so if you consider the
hypergraph h1
then if you can prove this mixing
results like this uh
then that will imply that any large
subset a within the group
is not going to be product free
uh okay all alternatively if you take a
to be b substitute on a gene large there
will be a non triple double like this
where all of them will belong to the
setting
and why is that so if you consider any
large uh subset a
uh then this
and you take the functions f to be all
of them to be the indicator function of
this set a the right side will be
something like negligible a positive
quantity
and uh
um by mixing it will follow the left
hand side will be also a non uh negative
with also
a positive quantity but if it a was
actually truly product free then the
left side must be identically zero so it
implies that a uh must be not product
free
so that's the argument
uh
and uh
the
if we consider uh i mean this kind of
mixing is not true for all kinds of
groups so if you just take the g to be a
billion and then this kind of making uh
will not happen uh and the reason is
that of course in a million groups there
actually are really large product free
sets so we cannot hope to get this kind
of results for all all groups
uh for example if you take z mod n if it
like a middle portion of it that will be
some free
uh like a um
significant uh fraction of them so uh
now the question you can ask like are
there any interesting groups where you
can hope to get such mixing uh and the
answer to that question is yes so in
2008 cowers and it's a
landmark paper uh
prove
that if you take g to be a finite d
quasi random groups then uh these two
terms we discussed about they'll be
close to each other now by
uh um
a model with this error term which is
one over square root of d now i i didn't
explain or define what d cos random
groups are uh i'll do that later
for a moment just think about you know
some parameters d is attached to the
group um
where d you should think about really
large integer values and
as you can see if d as d grows larger
and larger this air term will goes to
zero
okay so ours uh proves precisely this
theorem
uh and now
um you might ask the same kind of
question what happens um but for the
other hyper graph h2 that we defined
and
as you can guess mixing for uh showing
mixing for this type of graph will give
us um basically give us this kind of
statement so any large um if mixing
happens then any large uh subset a will
not be progressively this is give it
gives us you know control over
uh the size of progression three sets so
uh so these are the kind of very natural
motivation from the arithmeticometrics
point of view a very natural question uh
behind starting this kind of uh mixing
phenomena
and for this graph
or sorry you know this hyper graph h2
covers conjecture uh that mixing
actually happens again
if you take g to be fine at the equation
in groups so you conjecture this kind of
mixing uh happens with erect term small
of one but this quantity goes to zero as
uh d grows
okay so this was uh the conjecture by
governs
and
the main result of this paper and the
only resultant paper is this proving
this conjecture so we proved this
theorem in the paper
so you take g if j is finitely cross
enemy groups you again you take three
functions all of them are bounded then
these two expectations we talked about
in the left hand side you are sampling
uh random r and something or admin
progressions feeding them to the these
functions on the right hand side we have
partner expectations they are close by
uh
up to this um error factor uh which goes
to zero
as uh d grows
okay
now just to uh put the resulted a little
bit on a more formal ground let me
define what these position groups are
and for this we're gonna record a little
bit like two definitions so the first
one is about group representation so
uh a representation row of a group g on
some finite dimensional vector space v
will be simply a group homomorphism
which is mapping you know the group
elements to
invertible linear transformations on the
vector space
okay so that's the definition of
representations and for us all the
vector spaces we'll be talking about
will be complex over complex numbers so
any time we talk about representation
that comes actually in a double format
row and b
but we only write row assuming there are
some implicit vector space
that we are um
working with
okay
and uh we write uh um
we write basically a dimension of uh
representation row we denote that by d
row which is simply the dimension of
vector space that is um associated with
example so here's the trivial
representation if you just consider
vector space uh complex numbers one
dimensionals you can set rho x to be one
for all x in g
another definition we're going to need
is the definition of irreducible
representations which is
uh so rho is called
reducible if there exists you know a
non-trivial subspace w within the vector
space v
such that basically rho x doesn't move
any member of w outside of the
then we have reduced representation
otherwise we just call it irritation
so with this definition
uh basically you can define uh what
quasi random groups are so our finite
group g is positive positive random if
it's all non-trivial irreducible
representations are at least d
dimensional now a billion groups are one
quasi random so our theorem
doesn't say anything about them so this
is errors are really large but there are
really good cos random groups
okay so that's kind of the definition
and just to compare our results with you
know known results so in 2013 tao showed
this mixing
proof this conjecture was for the
specific group sldfq using algebraic
geometric machinery
then pelus in 2018 uh extends the result
to all finite simple groups and uh the
way she do is uh is this she reduced
this to bounding a sum like this
uh where rho is uh all risk from summing
over all possible
uh
irreducible representation and this sum
is zeta g minus one where this quantity
zetas is called witness it a function
and this can be bounded by a non-trivial
result by liebeck and charlotte from
2004.
for us we proved this conjecture for
all quasi random groups and the key
feature of the proof is we do not use
anything fancy or our proof is
completely elementary and uses basic um
fourier analysis
so that's more or less it and just to
conclude we showed mixing of three term
progressions
uh natural question is can we show uh
mixing for k term progressions and can
we find interesting applications for
complexity theory
thank you very much does anyone have any
questions
for syria
a quick quick question
for me so
is there a reason like uh where you
prove that doesn't extend to longer
progressions and do the previous works
that she handled longer progressions
so we have like a special cases of
longer program progression we do not
have it and we do not know any
result uh for longer progressions uh for
this kind of mixing uh generally
um not even for specific groups
especially in the sense that like
setting is different but uh one
difficulty kind of there are two kinds
of difficulties first of all all in
norway not a billion case kind of the um
we need to apply kind of uh so the way
proof goes in the first we kind of have
to apply repeated quasi shorts and that
kind of uh gets uh stuck for longer
progressions you know uh it kind of
becomes very complex to deal with um
things that comes out of the
control and on the
uh and they can then again we have to
think about you know proper definition
of some kind of probably uh uniform
gauss uniforming norms in this
non-billion case so those kind of those
two kind of difficulties are there but
first difficulties you know dealing with
fossil fuels itself simplifying
expressions
for longer progressions
um
yeah
i think shakhara has another question
but uh maybe shakkar you can ask us on
the chat and we can move on to the next
speaker
shut the screen
yes
yes
hi so uh this is a
joint work with uh tumeric hours
so
um this work is about
products in groups and there's really
two ways in which we can present it we
can talk about communication complexity
or mixing
and these two things are basically
equivalent and this being a computer
science conference i'm going to start
with the communication complexity and
then move to mixing
um just want to point uh
point out the survey on my
home page
which gives some background on these
questions in case you're interested
but now i'm going to dive right through
a
right to a problem
so let's consider a very simple walmart
problem uh let's say that you have a
final group
g you should think of g being large
but finite and you have two parties
alice involved alice gets an element x
from the group and bob also gets element
of y from c group and they want to know
if x times y is equal to one in the
group okay and allowed to use public
randomness
so this one problem has a very simple
solution
bob can compute in his head with no
communication and the inverse of y okay
and now to check if x y is equal to 1 is
the same thing as to check if x is equal
to the inverse of y which can be done
with constant communication
get a probability for equality
okay things get more interesting uh if
you said you have three parties can you
see what we started you know is alice
bob and close so ellis gets an element
in her hands so she knows x and nothing
else bob gets y and chloe gets z and
again they they want to know if x times
y and z is equal to one okay and
interestingly now the communication
complexity depends on the group
so if the group is a billion or
commutative then you can get constant
communication okay and this result
is not trivial you may think of like
hash functions but for the
domains like the silk group but there
are no exact hash functions so you have
to use almost
uh
almost as functions
but it can be done
and this constant communication extends
to what i'm going to call almost a
billion groups
uh these are groups uh which contain in
a billions a group of constant density
which you know in the group's radical
lingua is called constant index
so even from even for almost a billion
groups uh you can get constant
communication
and one question that i want to
highlight
right now is whether this thing is is an
infinite right is it true that
the communication is constant if and
only if the group is almost a billion uh
this question i think it's nice uh will
not answer it
um
otherwise another important family is
groups which were introduced by gowers
and which we just saw in the previous
soccer um
so here you can prove
that the communication is large you can
think of it as large constant exactly
as a growing function exactly how large
it depends on the randomness parameter
uh but again you can think of it as a
growing
country and
there is a gap between almost a billion
and brazilian groups okay and this works
uh
studies
uh groups in this uh uh you know in this
gap
uh aiming you know to answer this
question here in particular so let me
give you some examples of some groups
which are in between them
so one such group is defined group is
the group of two by two minuses over a
final field fq with entries a1 a2
0 and 1 when a1 is not zero this group
is neither a billion uh nor
the random another example which is a
kind of computer science friendly is the
so called the finite lambda lidar group
which can written as a z2 reflow at the
zn this this is a you know a
nice description the elements are n bits
x1 x2 xn are just bits and then you have
a shift s which is an element of the zm
and
the
the multiplication of two elements uh
works as follows
uh you first shift the x's by s you just
uh rotate them and then you sum
coordinate wise
okay uh so you can think of the beats as
lamps they can be either on or off
and s is the position of the lamp light
uh you know who goes up and turning and
turns on and off the lamps
and
the third example is actually family of
groups so you can consider
product groups uh g is equal to h to the
power n for any h which is another
billion for example uh h is constant
size
our main results uh in terms of
communication complexes are these ones
so again we consider this problem of
designing effects since y and z is equal
to one
for the fn group we prove a tight bounds
so the communication complex is state
and log the size of the group so you can
do nothing but send
all the inputs
for the lamplighter group we also prove
it tight bounds and now the bounds are
set of log log
the size of the group
and for product groups uh for any age
that's not a million we can put a lower
bound of omega log n and here it's open
if you can get a boundary like theta of
n
okay this was the
communication complex the viewpoint let
me now turn to mixing
so there are
three types of groups to consider so one
are the groups that don't mix um
so what's in the mix it means that you
can find
x and y which are independent
distribution over the group
which have high entropy so they are
uniform over say constant fraction of
the group but somehow if you multiply
them so if you sample from x and then
sample from y and then you put the
product
you don't get the uniform over the
entire
uh in style group okay and this
corresponds to this the first example of
hyper graphs that was in the in the pre
in the previous work okay
at the other end of the spectrum you
have quadrantum groups which
for every x and y as above you you do
mix completely so x and y becomes close
to uniform
and we study groups which are in between
uh so um
in our setting for every x and y is
above x terms white doesn't get
completely uniform but it gets somewhat
closer to uniform okay and the main
conception contribution of this work is
this new this new notion of
mixing wasn't meant to get closer to
uniform so uh here's our definition
we're going to say that that group g
mixes via a certain distribution f on
function from the group to the group if
the distribution is a non-trivial so f
of x is different from x often
and
if you multiply x and y as above
they become invariant under f so the
distribution x x y is close in
statistical distance to the distribution
f of x y so you
you get to pick one application of f
for free uh
this definition is sufficient for
communication complexity application
almost a billion groups don't mix
positive unknown groups allow you to
take f to be a random function and for
our groups you need different choices
for f so i'm going to quickly tell you
what's the choice
for f in each type so if the group is a
fine
f
can just set the one coordinate of the
matrix to uniform okay and it's actually
the strongest possible mixing because
you can show that you cannot touch x1
oh yeah thanks if you're the lamplighter
group
um
you can replace the bits here with the
uniform selection of bits which have the
same parity
and again this thing is the strongest
possible mix because you cannot change
the parity of the bits and you you you
you cannot change the shift s
for for
uh um
f um
uh selects a uniform coordinate and
picks a random conjugate
of that element in fact you can also
represent by uniform in some cases
so in other words the product
distribution becomes invariant under
randomizing one element of the top one
uniform
okay
and very quickly we use a representation
theory and equilibrium that we use is
that we prove and use is this that
if x and y are distributions like before
independent and high entropy
the product distribution can be
approximated
by
irreducible
re representations with the load
summation okay and then the results uh
use the representation theory of the
specific groups
thank you
thank you
does anyone have a question
um i have a question
yeah
so you mentioned that you get one
application of the mixing function f for
free um
i noticed that uh the first two examples
uh were
uh that doesn't matter because the f is
item or uh you got the same distribution
no matter what yeah but for the third
example it looked like you could apply
it twice and get some a different
distribution than just applying it once
but it seems like applying it twice
should be okay if you use two epsilon is
that true
yes thank you very much for the question
exactly so you've actually in the
setting or black group so you you can
apply f multiple times um and
um
you know
you can get i think you can randomize
like the polynomial number of
coordinates you can randomize entry apps
no coordinates and you will still you
will still be okay if you randomize more
you get into trouble like because uh
these distributions may just fix one
coordinate
so you're not allowed to randomize
that
okay so you can randomize up to like a
polynomial nominal coordinates
maybe more
maybe anywhere again or something you
still get something
that makes sense thanks
thank you
yeah thank you very much i guess let's
move on to the next thing here
okay
yeah can you hear me yes okay good
uh okay uh hello to everyone uh my name
is alex stankovic and uh i come from kth
institute of technology
which is based in stockholm sweden uh
and i will be talking about max trilling
over non-billion groups with
universal factor graphs uh this is a
joint work with ame bengali who is
working at university of california
riverside
okay
so
let me start by discussing the outline
of this talk
so
first i will discuss approximability of
max triline over general groups
then i will introduce the notion of
universal factor graphs and highlight
some of the research on this topic
and i will finish the talk by telling
you about our result
so let's begin
in the max trillion problem over f2
we are given a system of equations in
which the terms are
zero unvalued and addition is taken
modulo 2.
the algorithmic goal is to maximize the
number of equations
it can be satisfied and
if all equations can be satisfied then
we can find an assignment using gaussian
elimination
otherwise
consider an algorithm that picks a
random assignment
then every left hand side in the
instance will be either one or zero with
probability one half
and hence half of all the equations are
satisfied in the expectation
so
this is a rather simple procedure and it
is natural to ask
whether there are better algorithms than
this
hosted in his seminar worked showed
among other things that beating the
random assignment is np hard
in particular hostage showed that for
every epsilon greater than zero
it is n be hard to distinguish the
following two cases
more than one minus epsilon fraction of
equations can be satisfied
or at most one half plus epsilon
fraction of equations can be satisfied
for the sake of gravity we usually just
say that max trillion is one minus
epsilon one half plus epsilon np hard
and we refer to term one minus epsilon
as completeness and to the term one half
plus epsilon is sounds
let us now discuss max trilling over a
general group g
in this case we have equations of form
x1 times a times x2 times b times
x3 is equal to h where the terms take
values in some fixed finite group g
let us remarket we think of g as being
fixed and of instance is increasing in
size
we split our discussion into two
distinct cases when she is a billion and
then g is not a billion
let us discuss the billing case first as
you already saw one example with g being
equal to f2
even for general abelian group
satisfiability is easy to check
again by using gaussian elimination
also
random assignment satisfies one over
size of g fraction of equations in
expectation
previously mentioned seminar result of
course that gives a matching hardness
and in particular shows that
max trillion over g is one minus epsilon
one divided by the size of g plus
epsilon and p hard
let us discuss non-billion g now
the situation here becomes very
different from any group for any group g
and in particular
even deciding satisfiability becomes
np-hard
was shown
in a result of goldman and russell
we still have one divided by the size of
g approximation given by taking a random
assignment
however this can be improved on
satisfiable instances by an elegant
algorithm
which gives us one divided by the size
of the commutator subgroup approximation
the size of the commutator subgroup is
typically smaller than the size of the
whole group hence in most cases this
gives us a better approximation
algorithm
let us give an overview of max 3 in our
non-abelian groups on unsatisfiable and
satisfiable instances
and in particular their approximation
and hardness
for unsatisfiable instances we have
one divided by the size of g
approximation given by
our discussion considering a random
assignment
which is matched by a harness result
showed by engebretson
and russell
for satisfiable instances the
approximately of a very mentioned
algorithm is matched by a recent
beautiful harnessed result of
bengali encode
the hardness results discussed
previously apply only to worst case
instances
in particular we know that some
instances are easier for example bonded
degree instances that is
instances in which the number of
occurrences
of each variable is bounded by a
constant
another example is given by instances
whose factor graph has bounded three
with
i will tell you what the factor graph is
soon
given these examples it is natural to
ask whether it is the case that we can
always extract useful information by
knowing the structure of an instance
however in order to study this problem
we need to formalize what structure
means
which we do by introducing factor graphs
factor graph essentially tells us how
the variables are connected in an
instance
in particular vector graph is a
bipartite graph with vertices being
variables and constraints
we connect each constraint with the
variables appearing in that constraint
for example c1 is connected to x1 x2 and
x3
and we can similarly fill in the
rest the only information about instance
f not contained in a factor graph is
information about constants a i b i and
h i
hence we can ask what makes max trillion
over g hard
is it the structure of the factor graph
is it the details about the constants
or is it maybe both together
as we have seen before factor graphs can
be a factor in making instances easy
but let us take the opposite u
and ask if there are factor graphs one
for each size of instances
which do not make task of approximating
the optimal value any easier
this study was initiated by feige and
joseph who introduced the notion of
universal factor graphs and universal
factor graph hardness
let us now discuss hardness with
universal factor graphs for max trillin
over g
we say that max trillin over g is c as u
of g and p hard
if we can restrict factor graphs of
instances to be over a certain family of
graphs
one for each size of instance
such that max trillion over g on these
distances is
c s and p hard
factor graphs can be defined on more
general problems and phi gene draws are
considered max 3 set for which they gave
77 divided by 80 plus epsilon
universal factor graph hardness
just the furthermore showed that all
apx-hard boolean max csps remain apx
hard in universal factor graph setting
although with worse constants compared
to the general case
elegant result of austrian brown coin
and hosted gives us optimal hardness for
many problems including
max trilling over g for a billion g
and this problem is in particular one
minus epsilon
one divided by the size of g universal
factor graph and b hard and max three
set is one seven divided by eight plus
epsilon u of g and p hard
however until now there were no
universal factor graph hardness results
for max trillion in non abelians i think
lexi have two minutes left
yeah we built in previous results by
giving optimal hardness results with
universal factor graphs for max trilling
in the non-billion setting
in particular we proved the following
theorem which gives universal factor
graph hardness of almost satisfiable
instances
for every epsilon and any finite
thunderbillion group g max trillion over
g is one minus epsilon one divided by
the size of g plus epsilon you have j be
hard
furthermore we also give a ufg harness
theorem for satisfiableness is with
optimal sunnis parameter
there is another interesting side of our
result in particular we get nicer
instances
so we are able to remove
constants appearing between variables
and inverses which appeared in the
previous work of incorporation and
others
and this makes our instances more
structured and since we're working with
hardness our result is stronger than the
previous two
and i want to also compare our result of
the previous works so the main
difference to the compared to the
previous work done by bengal in cot
comes from the fact that we need to
handle universal factor graphs so we
need to generalize lemons in this work
apart from this proof is mostly the same
as the previous one
our proof has more differences compared
to the
previous result and almost satisfiable
instances so removing inverses requires
us to use a new pcp test
which is arguably more natural and
subsequent analysis is completely new
and more subtle than the previous one
and the main difference to the universal
factor graph result in a billion setting
consistent using four analysis for
general groups
and final level of detail used in the
knowledge of bengali cut so in case
three is a billion
the proof discussing on a billion part
become trivial and our result reduces to
the previous work completely
with all this being said i would like to
conclude my talk
so thank you does anyone have a quick
question
okay
so i mean is are there some other
problems for which you can use like
non-available analysis to prove hardness
approximation apart from constrained
satisfaction
[Music]
i'm actually not certain i'm mostly
working with csps
but i assume that's that's probably the
case yeah maybe someone else knows that
better
uh
okay yeah
let's move on to the next speaker
someone can answer in the chat if they
have a better answer
uh you have to stop sharing your screen
yes yes
okay
uh can you guys see the screen
uh yes
cool yeah so okay so let's get started
um so yeah so i'm gonna talk about the
separating growth in the problem from
new growth in the problem so this is
doing work with obviously body problem
materials dna
um so our problems like those this like
very simple um matrix optimization
problem so our input is n by n matrix a
now that can be rectangular
uh and then our goal is to find like two
vectors x and y um so they are like both
plus minus one vectors to maximize this
by linear form x transpose of a1
um and then yeah unlike many problems
actually that the um the of the
objective function value over this um
for some solutions can be negative but
then one can just like um easily see
that the opal value is always a
non-negative so one can uh define
approximation ratio
um and then uh in particular like
rotated in 1953 like gave a like very
nice constant vector versus algorithm
the stp rounding and then since then
this problem found the various
applications uh to function analysis
conversation optimization
and then today we're gonna be interested
in the discussion uh which is like the
what's the best approximation ratio to
buy any point in the channel
okay so what's the state of the art
okay so yeah we said like within it gave
a constant vector approximation and then
the the caribbean in 77 um gave a one
point seven eight two a prospection
algorithm which is like slightly
improved by braver nato i mean 2013 and
then all them were achieved by sdp
rounding
and then like kg is like this a constant
which is like the worst integral they
get uh for um the stps
and then for the other side so the
explicit lower bound for kg is currently
like 1.6769 by divine release and then
using this like put an adorable uh give
the matching on hardness assuming the
uniqueness conjecture
okay so they proved that like um it's a
assuming gives it some npr to to
approximate this problem better than
1.6769
and then surely after that graven
translator um said that no matter what
kg is it's gonna be like ug hard uh to
approximate this problem better than kg
okay so that's the state of uh assuming
unique in darkness but then if you want
the npr test without assuming uniqueness
conjecture then the best hardness is
actually on pi over two which is one
point five eight so this is done by
bread right saket um in 2015.
um but then another special case we will
look at which is called the lyric
authentic is when like a is a psc matrix
okay so in that case like there is a pi
vertical processing shell with them and
then indeed the hardest result of a
brilliant umbrella zaquette actually
holds um even when i use a psd so when
there is a pst for a little growth in
the problem
uh the pi over two is that the right
answer
okay so yeah but then yeah one can see
that um in terms of nprns so the general
quadratic problem and then the linear
gradient problem have the same hardness
until um recently and then my our main
result
uh is like to separate the growth in the
problem um from a new growth problem so
our main result is that um since the
entire approximate protein problem
within the factor slightly um better
than pi over two okay so that separates
those two problems
and then our technique wise that we um
do like slightly more like global and
more direct analysis uh unlike the nick
games conjecture
based artist so it may be useful for
other problems as well
okay so let me um say a few words about
our techniques um but then yeah before
do this actually let me briefly tell you
about um
what are the ingredients even for the
medium surface
okay so um yeah as usual like those
things are like proved via like
constructing details tests
and then for us that we can assume that
um the hour like matrix or operator a
is an operator that maps like the r
dimensional boolean function to another
like boolean function
so that we can treat like vector f and g
as a boolean functions obviously two
three are dimensional
um then um as usual like then what we
want from this like operator a is that
if f and g are details then we wanted
our values good
and if f and g are like far from
dictators then we wanted our values for
so there are like several candidates
that are used on to prove hardness of at
least assuming unit gains then the first
one is i simply did one projection
okay so um yeah so like you can um yeah
so given like f and g are like building
functions then we can do usually like
three analysis on f and g
and then the first section on the try
for a is just like degree one projection
which is that a is just like the
projector that projects any boolean
function so it's a linear part
then yeah one can see the different f
and g are dictators and details are
linear functions so value is preserved
uh but then if the f is far from
dictators then there's like the standard
like a boolean function here uh called
the pi two over pi theorem um saying
that in this case the linear paragraph
should behave like a gaussian with
variance at most two over pi so then one
can easily say the sound this value is
at most two over pi
it's that song yeah that gives you like
um two over pie hardness assuming
uniqueness conjecture
but then in order to go slightly beyond
so then what colton odonnell did or
based on the operator concept by david
reeds is to introduce like this a little
bit of penalty term minus lambda times
identity
okay so if you do this then yeah we
basically um rely on this like a
previous analysis for degree of one
projection but then you know they're
like some side cancellation between
linear part of f and then f is l okay so
if you just um do the calculations it's
gonna give you like slightly better
hardness
okay so that's uh for um called another
one and then those kind of dictators
tests uh can be plotted in um the unique
enzyme very easily and then give you the
matching hardness
but then unlike unique games if you want
to prove np harvest then it's going to
be much harder to plug those dictators
fast with the npr problems for example
label cover
but then somehow like rear drag of saket
um i'm succeeded in proving the optimal
hardness for um little growth in the
problem for like psc matrices
again yeah so they reduce from the
equipment
which means that for like each vertex of
the label cover they introduce a
dictatorship test
okay so then if you look at the overall
operator a then like it's going to be an
n times two tr by n times two to the r
on dimensional electrics where like n is
number versus the label copper
and then so this is their like entire
legume operator
so again like f1 is the the local
projection operator to linear part that
takes like the collection of boolean
functions and then like projects each
boolean function it's a linear part so
it's kind of very local but then this
like operator p
is a global operator that projects the
linear parts of each of all functions to
the label covered compatible space
which is like which depends on other
vertices and then they're like
interconnections okay so p is like
really global operator then it's really
hard to see what's going on there
because it depends on the the limb
coverage
um so like a p is really hard but then
somehow like managed to like um get
something out of it i'm crucially using
the fact that a is a psd because like if
a is a psd make sure it's like this then
one can consider the square root of a
and then like um we interpret the same
problem as our um optimization problem
over the l2
okay so here like we are like maximizing
over like a vector f prime which is lt
bounded
and then once you have like such a um l2
bound that actually on the projection
becomes like somewhat nice because like
it looks like the projection um
decreases l too long
and then you are left with the pf bar of
pf prime which is a level cover
compatible with the l2 node and then
these two effects alone like or were
sufficient to get like optimal power to
harness for like a pst instances
but then of course um our work um is
like trying to go beyond pi over two
which necessarily means that our like
matrix or shouldn't be pst
okay so we mean that we cannot use this
like a nice trick and then our analysis
should be like more direct and global
okay so this is our like final reduction
so we basically took the hard distance
for pi over two
and then again like um uh subtracting
some copy of identity for like some
small number greater than zero so it's
like really like similar to dangerous
operator for uniqueness hardness though
like our analysis had to be global and
then we lost like some um many things in
the analysis so like numbers are not the
same
okay so yeah um and then to briefly say
how we probably solve this so suppose
that um g transpose af is an optimal
solution
uh then um yeah what you can say is that
let f f prime
uh be f
after applying the linear projection and
then the label cover projection and then
same for like g prime
okay so then one can write the objective
function value as an inner product
between g prime and f prime and then the
inner product between g and f times
lambda
and then yeah one can actually say that
the previous like the proof technique uh
implies that f prime and g prime are
like not that low their length and two
length is bounded by square root of two
pi
and then again just like kind of target
region analysis our like analysis is
kind of being mean again
so yeah one case they definitely f and g
are closed
then this like second term here
so lambda times like g inner product
degenerm will like kick in so they will
subtract the sounds value so like we're
gonna get low soundness
and then also if f prime and g prime rf
r then of course like the first term
will be small and then we're going to
get the low soundness
okay so
left sure thanks yeah and then yeah but
then
the difficulty is that f prime
is uh f but after like applying the
um local projection which may be fine
but they have and then like this like
global version more crucially
okay so like f is um yeah prime and f
can be like vastly different and then so
are like g and g prime so it's um the
game is to like um relate the
relationship between f and g and the
relationship with that primary g prime
okay so yeah that was our main challenge
but then like briefly the way we handle
this issue
is that so assuming that um g and f are
form the optimal solution then we know
that it's a bilinear optimization which
means that given f once you fix f then g
is the optimal choice given f
and then g is a plus minus one vector so
then what you're saying is that um so if
you look at g
then g should be the n2 y sine over f
prime minus lambda n
and then same thing we should hold for f
as well f should be the entry y sine
over g prime minus lambda g
okay so given this cyclone kind of the
the zigzag relationship then yeah what
you said is that if like f prime is on
close to g prime
then yeah we prove that sine of which f
prime should be sine of g prime
so
uh um at the end we have our g is kind
of close to sine of f prime which is a
close to sign of g prime which is cosine
sine of life f okay so like if i prime
and g prime are closed and g and f
should be closed as well okay so that's
um how we achieved this win-win analysis
and then we got um something slightly
better than pirate taurus
okay so that was all on briefly our um
our proof
and then of course like the main problem
is to get a better impairments for
growth ending of course if you want to
match the kg and partners but then press
like the first step is to like get the
same hardness as the grease lower bound
because the cover like um operator it's
really like a w zom door bound
and then finally um since our technique
is kind of like um
this um mix of a
project the label covered subspace
operator and then global analysis so we
are hoping that like this um technique
may be useful somewhere else
okay so that's it and thank you
okay uh thank you
if anyone has a quick question because
we are out of time with this talk so
maybe they can type it on the chat and
let's move on to the next week
uh can everyone seeking my screen
yes
awesome should i start
yeah
awesome so this is uh convex influences
and it's trying to work with
an india day and rockers of radio
so super high level um
this talk is about a sort of an analogy
between monotone boolean functions on
the n-dimensional hypercube and
symmetric convex steps so just just
remind everyone a monotone boolean
function is just a zero one valued
function
that's monotone in each coordinate um
in other words if you flip an input from
zero to one the value of the function
doesn't
decrease and
a convex set is symmetric if it's
symmetric about the origin or in other
words if a point x is in the set then
the point minus x obtained by
flipping the sign of each of excess
coordinates is also in the set
and so it's just symmetric about the
origin
and over the past you know 10 or so
years many sort of structural and
algorithmic analogies have sort of
emerged between
these two seemingly different settings
so
um just to give a little bit of
background um monotone and boolean
functions are super well studied and
they show up very naturally in
combinatorics and statistical physics
and complexity and a lot is known about
their analytics structure learnability
and things of this sort
but you can ask these the same questions
for um
symmetric convex sets as well and
people have obtained many corresponding
results for symmetric convex sets of
course you sort of
replace the
the fourier parity basis with the
hermite basis of the gaussian space and
you replace uniform distribution running
with learning under the gaussian
distribution but for the most part you
know a lot of the results are
um very similar um
and
um
and this work sort of extends this
analogy and
the starting point of this work is
actually correlations inequalities which
i don't talk about in which i won't talk
about today but i i sort of tell the
story about how we
how we got to what i'll be talking about
in the in the full version of this talk
so in particular this this work um
introduces a new notion of influence
with symmetrical sets um
which is analogous to like the usual
notion of influence
um for boolean functions so just to
remind everyone if you've got
a boolean function f um
you can define the influence of any of
its n coordinates as the probability
that when you choose a point uniformly
at random from the boolean hypercube the
value of the function of that point
differs from the value of the function
at the point of pin by flipping
that particular bit
and this is sort of a very natural
quantity which is intuitively capturing
how much a function depends on a
particular coordinate
and there's been a long line of really
awesome work you know starting with the
kkl theorem um that's
built upon that builds upon this notion
of influence
and um
our analogous notion of influence for
symmetric convex sets turns out to be
this this following analytic expression
so first of all um over the boolean
hypercube there's n canonical directions
right there's n coordinate directions
but
when you're in in gaussian space when
you're in rn you don't really
have any um canonical basis so you can
sort of it makes sense to define
influence along any direction
and
and so this notion of influence which we
call convex influence is the expectation
of the indicator function of the set
times
essentially the second hermite
polynomial
evaluated along that direction and this
might seem like a weird arbitrary
quantity but there's a there's a much
more natural way of looking at it and
and so i'm not going to focus too much
on this analytic definition um and i'll
focus on the more intuitive one which
i'll show you in a second
so
so an an easy intuitive characterization
of of this convex influence
is as follows so say say you're
interested in the influence of a
symmetric convex set k along the first
coordinate direction so e1 is just the
first coordinate basis vector
um
and you can define this matrix m sub
delta where you're sort of dilating
your convex body by tiny amount by one
plus delta along the first direction and
you're fixing all the other directions
you're not doing anything in other
directions
and then the influence is nothing but
the rate of change of the gaussian
measure the rate of change of the volume
of the set when he's sort of dilating it
along the direction and this is
analogous to the russo marvelous lemma
for um boolean functions if you know
what that is
but in terms of pictures if you're
starting with the symmetric convex set k
um you stretched it by a little bit
along this first direction e1
and you see how much the volume changes
um
and you sort of take this limit of this
change in the volume
to the scaling factor this delta
as as you send delta to zero
hopefully this is
this feels slightly more intuitive than
the analytic um
hermet polynomial definition of
influence
but um just to make sure that we're not
doing something completely insane um i
guess the first question to ask is
whether you know
this convex influence is not negative so
the boolean influence is just a
probability so it's obviously going to
be between zero and one and so it's
reasonable to ask if the convex
influence is sort of similar right
and
if you think about this dilation
definition
um
of of convex influence it's not really
clear why it should be non-negative
right because just from this picture
when you dilate along a certain
direction
it's not necessarily the case that this
new body is
this new body contains the original body
it's not clear that the gas that the
gaussian measure the gaussian volume
increases
but um fortunately because of the lower
concavity of the carboxyl measure um it
it's it's sort of an easy
easy exercise to show that this convex
influence actually is always positive
for symmetric convex sets so you just
sort of look at the
gaussian n minus one dimensional custom
volumes of cross sections and and
express this new volume as an integral
and just as a is sort of a very short
three-line exercise and so the convex
influence is indeed non-negative so it
sort of passes the first sanity check
um another sort of reasonable question
to ask is you know what does zero convex
influence possibly mean so in the
boolean setting since it's the
probability that when you flip a
particular coordinate uh the value of
the function changes if the probability
is zero then the function is completely
independent of that coordinate it just
doesn't depend on that coordinate and
something analogous holds here where if
the
influence of a certain direction on your
convex body
is zero then
that your convex body is essentially a
cylinder along that direction so sort of
an n minus one dimensional convex body
um
which is just sort of like you take a
cylinder along the direction which has
zero influence up to a set of measure
zero um so really it's like independent
of that direction
so
so far again you know both of these
things sort of check out and it doesn't
seem super insane
um and so the third
easy standard d check is is to ask what
analogs of some extreme boolean
functions are
in in the setting of symmetric unlike
stats
and so um
i won't go over how we calculate the
influences but um
just to sort of give some integration
the dictator function of the cube which
is just a projection onto a particular
particular coordinate um has
zero influence for all the coordinates
you're not for every coordinate but the
one you're projecting on and the
analogous symmetric convex body turns
out to be just a slab along a certain
direction so it's just all of gaussian
space in
all of our
in all directions but with the one
you're looking at
and in both cases
all other coordinates all irrelevant
coordinates do have influence zero
um
another sort of extremely boolean
function is the majority function um
which intuitively is capturing the top
half of the boolean hypercube
um and the analogous body is is is just
this the ball of radius root n which is
essentially sort of capturing the the
inner half
of rn of gaussian space and in both
cases again the influences are of each
coordinate direction is is one over root
n um up to constant factors and finally
another female boolean function is the
tribes function this is sort of famously
extrema for the kkl theorem
um
and the analog of the tribes function
turns out to be the solid cube of side
length square root log n
um
and
and again both cases the influences
don't have to be optical constant
factors log n over n
uh so shift we only have a minute okay
awesome things um
so
so far we've passed all these three
sanity checks but the main results of
this paper are actually um
pointing towards a much deeper analogy
between these two settings so
in particular we are able to get a
poincare analog a kkl analog prove sharp
threshold results for convex sets and
and and you know show density increment
results like microscope theorem and
as well as proof sort of a weak feed
gunta theorem and i just want to
emphasize that our proofs are very
different so
as a concrete example the kkl proof
relies strongly on hyper contractivity
but we sort of just use
tools from convex geometry and gaussian
isoparametric there's no
hypercontractivity in the picture
and this work sort of suggests many
natural open directions um in particular
the kkl theorem we prove is
quadratically weaker
and it'd be interesting to get
algorithmic results and as well as a
free good hyundai theorem
um i think i'm out of time so thanks for
listening any questions
uh
so thank you does anyone have a question
so i was wondering you know what happens
you know does this definition not make
sense if you don't have like a convex
set
so it actually makes sense for um
it makes sense for non-convex sets as
well but it's not necessarily
non-negative it can be zero or it can be
it can be it can be negative yeah okay
um like if you just think the dilation
characterization works for
basically any measurable stat
so if you don't have a
symmetric convex set if you just have a
set far away from the origin when you
dilate it it's causing magic can
decrease and so the influence will be
negative yeah
all right i guess so
so
this pretty much answers the session so
if anyone has any questions for the
speakers they can hang out and ask now
otherwise uh i think
you're free to go
so thank you again to the speakers
thanks
uh so even uh
okay sign up
all right
thank you